BENCHES WERE ON THAT IN THE
SHORT TIME.
>> THE LINE.
CAUFIELD DROPS IT OFF.
POKE CHECK. PETRY WHO HAS
TWO GUYS DOWN LOW NOW, AND
MRAZEK MAKES A GREAT FIRST SAV
RE-ESTABLISH SOME CONFIDENCE"A"G
WITH MARNER, NYLANDER, MATTHEWSF
SHORTHANDED GOALS AS WELL.
MARNER HAS A COUPLE ON THE
SEASON. ANDERSON AND PLAYS IT
DEEP BEHIND THE CANADIENS NET.
SPEZZA TAKES IT AWAY, P
UNDERTAKES IT IN T
ENTIRE TIME ON THE BENCH.
>> Chris: HERE'S ALLOWS
DOWN GALLAGHER.
AWAY GOES HOFFMAN. RACES.
LILJEGREN HESITATION FOR A
SECOND, LITTLE POINT TO TRY TO
MAKE SURE THE P NINTH OF THE  T
GLOVEDEZZETTA
BACK IN. STEP UP.
TAVARES BATTLINGTREAK HE WASN'T
AFRAID AT ALL TO THINK SHOOT
FIRST INSTEAD JUMPS ON THE LOOS
BEATS HIS MAN AROUND, AND BOY,
N AND IT'S
4-0!
BOUNCING PUCK IN FRONT OF
DERMOTT, GOOD SUPPORT BY
CAUFIELD, THE TRAILER IS LEFT
TO
THE OTHER WAY.
BRENDAN GALLAGHER, WITH PITLICK
DIFFICULT ONE.
THIS GOES OFF A PANT LEG OF
MIKHEYEV.
REILLY DZONE.
THAT MATCHES A CAREER BEST FOR
MIKHEYEV HIS EIGHTH OF.
THIS IS JUST A NICE DRIVE WENT .